ja wir sind ja bei der diskussion die
mir fehlt nämlich dass wir zwar mit
hohen militärischen sachverstand
inzwischen so wie wir auch eine zeitlang
ja alle virologen war
überwachen diskutieren wie gut wie
beweglich wie schnell wie treffsicher
sie sind also immer irgendwie politisch
bleiben aber die frage der politischen
verantwortung dabei wie weit können wir
mitgehen wie weit geht eine
unterstützung für einen überfall eines
land wie die ukraine wo sind da die
grenzen oder würden wir auch mitgehen
wenn die ukraine gesagt jetzt sind wir
so stark jetzt zeigen wir es den russen
mal und wir greifen auch russisches
territorium an die amerikaner wollen das
offenkundig nicht bei uns wird die
diskussion nicht geführt beim kanzler
glaube ich schon dass das was ihm als
zögern und zaudern immer vorgeworfen als
genau diese nachdenklichkeit und
besonnenheit ist verdammt noch mal wie
weit kann ich gehen ohne dass die
risiken nicht zu groß werden wie
reagiert der mensch im kreml den ja
keiner mehr für berechenbar wirklich
hält das kann ich also nachvollziehen
die öffentlichkeit diskutiert dass nicht
die medien nicht die sind auch alle auf
dem trip möglichst viel co2 und für die
po das ist ein skandal dass die polen
jetzt nicht die leo zwei kriegen obwohl
sie die neueste version haben will von
denen nur die bundeswehr nach meinem
wissen schon maximal 20 haben müssen wir
nicht erst selbst die haben also all das
wird und diese diskussion muss geführt
werden
auch unter dem aspekt dass zwar der
kanzler zurückhaltend ist ich habe es
schon eben gesagt frau baerbock aber
immer von gewinnen der ukraine rede und
herr merz richter gestern hingestellt
hat die wahrung und scholz gefragt hat
warum sagt herr scholz nicht einfach die
ukraine muss diesen krieg gewinnen auch
er hat diesen begriff nun ist es auch
ein matches prinzip so ähnlich wie bei
herweck immer fragen zu stellen die die
beiden nicht beantworten dass er deren
stil der rhetorik aber er benutzt den
begriff gewinnen dann muss ich auch
sagen was gewinnen heißt heißt es jetzt
eine rückkehr zu den frontlinien oder
wie heißt das kontakt linien vor dem 24
februar heißt dass ein rückgewinn des
donners und der krim die ukraine oder
heißt dass sogar und den russen ein paar
vernichtung in grenzen zu zeigen nie
wieder liebe leute oder heißt es
irgendwo müssen wir eine linie haben sie
haben es vorhin gesagt henry kissinger
hat das in schonungsloser offenheit
gesagt was mir mehr bedeutet als das was
er sagt sondern dass er immer noch im
weißen haus zu gast ist das ist
natürlich intern die amerikanische
überlegung und ohne die usa wären die
ukraine nicht so weit wie mir ist es
auch egal ob ich dann als putin verstehe
oder als ukraine vertreten da stelle ich
finde diese politische debatte ist
überfällig unterdrücken will
ist es gibt ein bundestagsbeschluss und
da ist klar festgelegt dass es so was
die hilfe so weit geht es ja immer schon
aufgezählt auf welchen ebenen und auch
auf militärisch aber das ist maximal so
weit geht dass deutschland nicht
kriegspartei
bezogen auf die waffen sagen weil er
beim 1 1 einen punkt völlig recht hat
diese dass die leute über waffen- oder
sagen sie selbst generäle ich bin kein
experte geht ungern über waffen in
teilen brauchen sie die zur
selbstverteidigung die ukraine kann uns
alles fordern uns entscheiden was sie
will das ist ein angriff ist ein
souveräner staat wir müssen entscheiden
wie wir der ukraine am besten helfen
können und was verantwortbar ist es ist
nicht verantwortbar etwas zu tun was uns
in den kriegen von immer ein beispiel
sagen
geraten wenn wir wir schicken waffen
aber die öffentlichkeit beschimpft uns
wir seien im grunde genommen zögerlich
das war ja auf 719 aber das ist eine
frage wie man sagen das ist meine
entscheidung der sache
ich denke wieder washington nach paris
nach rom noch london liefert kam panzer
oder kampfflugzeuge westlicher baut
warum nicht es gibt diesen ringtausch
mit den panzern sowjetischer macht hat
diesen polen also stellen sie sich mal
vor ein deutscher leo das sind keine
group.com keine verletzten bei austern
haben wir 50 getöteten sozusagen mit dem
deutschen panzer wir haben das in gang
gesetzt die konsequenzen die sowas haben
würde und deswegen will ich schon sagen
wir müssen immer überlegen verantwortbar
ist aber noch ohne irgendwas auch
scheinheilig ist ohne den eindruck zu
erwecken und das wird ja eben sehr
emotionalisiert ihr laste im stich das
darf man übrigens auch nicht diesen
langem ich finde der probleme sind
kriegsverbrecher gehört auch nach
dritten um bereich alles keine frage da
ist der lizenz nicht aber dieses
ausschließlich denken die militärische
logik und was heißt gewinnen verlieren
ich benutzen lassen oder schaust du das
auch juli nach dem krieg nicht will die
an wo es dann darf ich nicht gewinnen
etwas völlig anderes das
heißt leider zerstört wir müssen das
land wieder vorn was hat das gestern
sogar variiert die ukraine muss bestehen
eher weniger als nicht nur verlieren sie
muss eigentlich ein hektar tieren also
ja dann auch gerne doch noch mal sagen
also sie haben völlig recht ja dass wir
die debatte nicht hören und auch noch
nicht ehrlich führen da vielleicht sind
wir auch endlich soweit ja weil wenn sie
nämlich um ja ja wir gestern wie auch
immer aber ich war damals ja und dieses
sagen wir wir müssen über
waffenstillstand reden der italienische
außenminister hatte am 18 mein vorschlag
gemacht ja die ärzte gegen den atomkrieg
haben vorschlag gemacht also es gibt
auch die anderen vorschläge ich finde ja
immer sprecher akt ja worüber man redet
wird dann wirklichkeit ich finde wir
reden zu wenig von dem was wir auch der
herr schulenburg ja der ehemalige es ist
ein genie von der nato hat diesen großen
artikel ich glaube cicero gemacht nur
gesagt hat europa hat in dieser rolle
dezidiert die rolle dass wir für den
frieden eintreten aber das liege und es
ist ja auch bei uns hier das territorium
also das ist noch mal was anderes als
die amerikaner was die vielleicht auch
verhandlung liegt noch ein bisschen
daran glaube ich dass die die eigene
jugend pro machtposition gehören
wissenschaftler journalisten diese
teilweise verlassen haben und an den
social media mit man nicht nur als
kombattanten kommen wissenschaftler und
sagen wir jetzt nicht mehr machen die
fertig sein und wir wollen ja keine
ahnung
was fehlt dir führen und maschinen
schweren waffen das ist auch ein
schmackhafter gemacht ich habe mich
gefragt haben muss ich einmal etwas
exotischer den journalisten auch die den
sozialen medien des am posten sind auch
meistens die die im gegensatz zu vielen
politikern vor ort waren und über monate
berichtet haben natürlich sind auch eine
haltung dazu haben sind immer trägt
unterhaltung wenn man nicht vor ort ist
kriegt nämlich sehr genau mit was da
stattfindet und dass ein brutaler krieg
ist da gibt es keine zwei meinungen ich
sage ihnen was macht in
unterschiedlichen teilen sie mit älteren
menschen gesehen jetzt kinder noch
gelebt hat oder wenn sie mit denen reden
in meiner generation die gegentore
musste und demonstrierte monats vor
kriegen das gefallen noch immer kann
dann kennen sie auch mit denjenigen die
krieg als social media wirklichkeit
manchmal könnte doch mal mit der nato
man kann nicht mit der nase wir reden
nicht über irak oder oder libanon sind
wir reden über die zweitgrößte atommacht
der welt was russland über uns immer
noch ist und was machen wir mal was
andere tun und deswegen sind wir doch
froh damit also dass gerade schon in
dieser nukleare eskalation und twitter
soziale hineingeredet haben und die
ersten schon dabei waren von der
kontrollierten eskalation zu sprechen
dass wir das wenigstens mal eingekesselt
habe ich sage nochmal ich zumindestens
beobachter seit ungefähr zwei wochen
dass ich das alles ein bisschen ein
deftig werte über uns auch die
zurückhaltung von herrn scholz die ihn
jetzt so lange vorgeworfen wurde als
eigentlich tatsache dafür dass unter der
hand schon längst versucht wird wo ist
eigentlich der verhandlungs entwurf hier
wo kommen wir eigentlich sozusagen aus
diesen heraus wurden die verdächtigung
gestrickt er hat ja in wirklichkeit ist
das was die leute wollen uns oder sägen
und jahren aber branchen rechnen hilft
halt trotzdem also glaube ich schon dass
es ein dass es ein problem ist dass er
sich sehr lange zurückgehalten hat und
damit nehme ich jetzt nicht positionen
für das eine oder andere aber er muss
eine entscheidung treffen da muss was
sagen wer kennt kann auch heißen nein
das machen wir nicht aber sagen dass
juristisch prüfen zum einen nicht dass
er sagen muss wie eine verhandlung durch
sein
muss kommen nicht an tiefer werden warum
er welche politik macht gehen haben
verstanden warum man ich wirklich
erklärt warum
er
nicht die zu gehen der deutsche im
schnitt findet ihr diese
nachdenklichkeit eher gut als dieser wir
wissen genau wo wir hin müssen aber es
ist irgendwie symptomatisch
ich gehe mal davon aus dass auch die
amerikaner sich das ja nicht so leicht
machen wenn ich dann höre dass die
wochenlang darüber beraten haben können
wir die mehrfach raketenwerfer liefern
oder ist das nicht doch zu riskant wahl
ist von putin als kriegseintritt
zumindest indirekter art gewertet werden
kann das hat aber öffentlich lange nicht
so heftig stadt wurden wie wir über jede
haubitze oder über jeden helm diskutiert
populistisch diese das wird diskussionen
zu führen denn ich muss den elisa makro
sagt überhaupt nichts über die frage
welche man aber nicht
und der amerikanische präsident hat um
es interessant dabei sein
verteidigungsminister zurückgepfiffen
der hatte nämlich gesagt wir müssen
russland daran hindern sie jemals wieder
stark wenn ich habe beiden hatten die
kriegsziele das anders steht aber nee da
steht aber jetzt so auch in einem
artikel der new york times
im gastbeitrag bei ja natürlich bei dem
verteidigungsminister war die
interpretation dass könne sozusagen ein
wechsel des regimes voraus dass das
haben die amerikaner hat das geht nie
gut es geht und russland schon gar nicht
ins unter war der versprecher aber
tatsächlich natürlich auch schon mal
auffällig
ist die debatte weit weniger heftig und
kontrovers in amerika ist ja selbst sind
ja selbst die republikaner dafür so geht
es nicht lieber protein- und natürlich
ist ich weiß ich bin journalist wie sie
durchaus ja wissen ich ziehe mir nicht
an als hätten ja auch nicht
als hätte ich jetzt eine lösung ich
investiere nur dass wir die debatte
wenigstens führen müssen weil jeder der
hier sitzt weiß ja die
verhandlungslösung ist in weiter ferne
solange putin glaubt er kann sich
leisten überhaupt nicht auf so etwas
einzugehen werden wir das machen sie für
verhandlungen nicht will ich würde
trotzdem noch mal ins feld führen wollen
ob unsere es samt uns also unsere
annahmen da immer so korrekt und ja also
es gibt einfach auch andere stimmen die
die frage ist welchen bedingungen ist
putin bereit zu verhandeln ja also wenn
also das ist
also das stichwort das natürlich
neutralität das ist das reizwort ja aber
wenn man das auf den tisch legen würde
ja und das eingeständnis machen würde
würde würde das vielleicht auch nicht
viel anderes zu holen ist ja dann ist
das vielleicht anders aus ich will nur
sagen wenn wir die rationalen sind in
diesem konflikt und immer denken dass
der andere boote in diesem fall
irrational ist ja dann würde ich sagen
gibt es viele andere stimmen die sagen
putin hat wenn ich über gründe ist nicht
irrational
gerade sagen dass putin nämlich brutal
und aggressiv ist aber durchaus rational
unserer diesen sound machen haben wir
das thema nicht mehr und das einst putin
ist nicht rational oder erst bestimmt
nach der sendung noch weitere
beweise zu ihm